El equipo y el mecanismo están dentro de una caja.
La pistola está arriba soldada a una placa de acero.
Hay un cable que va hasta el gatillo,
y la computadora de la caja está en línea.
Recibe la información del 911 del Departamento de Policía de Nueva Orleans,
por eso cada vez que se informa un tiroteo en Nueva Orleans,
(Sonido de bala)
el arma se dispara.
Es de fogueo, no hay bala.
Hay un flash y un gran un estruendo,
y lo más importante, hay una carcasa.
Hay unos cinco disparos al día en Nueva Orleans,
por lo que durante los cuatro meses que duró la instalación,
la caja se llenó de balas.
Ya saben qué es esto; se llama "visualización de datos".
Si lo hacen bien, es revelador.
Si lo hacen mal, insensibiliza.
Reduce las personas a números.
Así que cuidado.
Una última obra para Uds.
Pasé el verano pasado como artista residente
para Times Square.
Y Times Square en Nueva York es literalmente el cruce del mundo.
Pero la gente no se da cuenta
de que es el lugar más instagrameado del planeta.
Cada cinco segundos alguien publica una selfie tomada en Times Square.
Son unas 17 000 al día, y yo las tengo a todas.
(Risas)
Estas son algunas de ellas con los ojos en el centro del marco.
Cada civilización usará la tecnología a su alcance para hacer arte.
Y es responsabilidad del artista hacer preguntas
sobre qué significa esa tecnología y cómo refleja nuestra cultura.
Por eso me despido con esto: Somos mucho más que números.
Somos personas y tenemos sueños e ideas.
Y reducirnos a estadísticas es algo que se hace por cuenta y riesgo propio.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)